so at approximately 12 p.m this
afternoon lvmp dispatch received a call
they
robbery in progress at a bank located
off of uh
charleston and las vegas boulevard
the robbery was still said to be in
progress so
upon arrival officers created a
perimeter around the location and we're
getting real-time info from within the
bank
armed robbery
was not an armed robbery that we were
aware of there was not no mention of a
weapon however there was still
something to the effect of a person had
come into the bank
and the teller assumed that there was a
robbery that was taking place
so then officers created a perimeter
around the location to make sure it was
deemed safe
and swat was called
upon their arrival they took the suspect
into custody without incident were there
any victims or anyone in the bank when
this was happening
uh the people that were in the bank at
the time were um
uh employees of the bank
and other customers that were in there
we believe fled prior to officers alive
as of right now the situation is over
the situation is over and is being
investigated by uh lvmpd robbery section
is anybody hurt or anything in this no
injuries how long do you expect to
expect the roads to be closed for here
uh the investigation is still ongoing i
can't give you a true time frame
that's it guys thank you thank you